what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so getting into Tom Taylor's hunt
for Wolverine adamantium agenda to be
honest when I first heard about this I
thought I was just gonna be like a
reworked extinction agenda right for
those you guys who don't know
extinction agenda was a story that came
out in 1990 and it was designed to kind
of create this transition between what
were the new mutants into x-force as
well as like the new reworked version of
x-factor and even the x-men themselves
largely it's centered around Cameron
Hodge who had basically just been a
holdover since the old Lewis and Walter
Simonson x-factor run uh he was a guy
who backed the x-factor team and then
ultimately turned out to be a bad guy he
was just kind of a guy who was there for
a while I know by that point he was a
cyborg 1990s comics well it really was
it was 1990 so it wasn't really it was
really even before 1990s comics but
still nonetheless I thought it was gonna
be like a reworked version of that not
at all it's actually kind of cool it's a
really really interesting concept now
like all the other hunt for Wolverine
many stories this basically focuses in
some form or fashion on the character of
warframe himself classic Logan and it
really deals really kind of sets the
stage for like what comes after you know
after the events of Wolverines return
and really like how these various teams
deal with it now initially this picks up
with new Avengers and to be honest I
feel like kind of an idiot because I
jumped on Twitter yesterday the day
before then I asked people I was I asked
question I said adamantium agenda is it
the Mighty Avengers or the New Avengers
that it picks up with because when the
New Avengers for okay a little bit of
history here I know a lot of you guys
just like get to the point a little bit
of history here so we'll say 1964 is
when the Avengers first popped up which
meant that running up to like 2004 they
had essentially been happy been been
going on for you know 40 years or
something along those lines and so what
ended up happening is under joe cassano
mauville got rid of them right they were
just like disband the Avengers cancel it
so we got Avengers disassembled and then
almost immediately after that happened
Brian Michael Bendis reworked the
Avengers team and gave us new avengers
picking up with the new Avengers team
what this does is it kind of goes back
when the team was relatively new not
brand new but was relatively new and it
basically picks up with like a bomb
that's been set now this you know in
this initial iteration I knew right off
the bat what direction they were gonna
go in and it's basically that Wolverine
is the one that stays behind because
what they say is that this bomb has
basically a kind of proximity alarm if
anybody were to touch it try to
dismantle it it would detonate if they
get too far away it would detonate is
one of these things worse like they're
all kind of screwed so somebody has to
stay behind and ultimately it ends up
being Wolverine
now there are some funny moments here
which is kind of cool there's a there's
a funny little moment here when
Spiderman says well you know okay you
know I'll be the one to do it and
Wolverine chimes and says no man the
radioactive spider that bit you is not
going to be able to run you back you're
not gonna be able to heal from it
now if spider-man's initial reaction is
how do you how do you know that and
Wolverines like come on dude you're
spider-man everyone's heard your origin
story and it's kind of like who hasn't
heard the origin story of spider-man
before and like the one agent from
shield just kind of raises their hand
which is the funny little thing this is
kind of a big deal because you've got
them yeah Jessica Jones you got Luke
Cage and this is designed to kind of say
these are the sacrifices that Wolverine
made now by and large given the whole
publication history of Wolverine things
like this could be overlooked pretty
easily right you know Wolverine he heals
from everything so doesn't really matter
but if you start looking in this for you
know looking at this from the
perspective of the character Wolverine
is going to essentially die yet again
like he's gonna be blown up yet again
and it's crushing and that's one of the
things that Jessica Jones kind of hits
on and it's not something you see very
often but in this moment she just kind
of says look thank you for what you're
doing here because without this we would
all die and Wolverine is kinda like yeah
that's the nature of the beast now the
crazy thing about this is that as the
bomb begins to detonate Wolverine
recognizes something and when he
recognizes something when he activates
this bomb and when he recognizes what's
there he basically says like you're
gonna have a ton of explaining to do
meaning something's off here and so what
we end up doing is picking up with Tony
Stark Mirman listening to himself and
musing over what had gone on with
Wolverine and the idea here is a Tony
Stark says I owe him one like I owe
Wolverine a pretty big thing now the
indication really seems to be that Tony
Stark owes him because Wolverine
basically detonated the bomb in place
and hepta from healing tons and tons and
tons of people but what he also says he
you know he kind of chimes into
spider-man who defeats the vulture
immediately which makes sense because
the vulture sucks and he basically says
look I have information on the idea that
the DNA of a super hero is going to be
sold now it makes perfect sense
that it's going to be Wolverine that's
the one thing that that really kind of
stands out when it comes to his
character one thing to bear in mind he's
the most sought-after person in the
entirety of the Marvel Universe now a
lot of that's done because of the fact
of his popularity
I mean Wolverine by the time his heat by
the time is his comic had been cancelled
and by the time he had died in the death
of Wolverine in the final issue he had
appeared in some 12,000 comic books he's
been on pretty much every single
superhero team out of all the superhero
teams that exists we can Nix off like
three and say he hasn't really been
but for the most part he's the most
sought-after person because in the
Marvel Universe he has a healing factor
he's one of the most trained assassins
people constantly chased after his DNA
and especially after he had died it's
like hey look if we can clone Wolverine
then we could have our very own version
of him they can essentially follow the
whole plethora of X 23 - her escaping
and running off in the sense that we can
basically be someone we send in for a
particular mission we can auction them
off to the highest bidder cuz we could
say look you paid ten million dollars
he'll assassinate some political figure
somewhere these are kind of big deals
and so what thewhat we end up finding
out is this entire deal is going down on
a submarine well this particular auction
but what they're doing is they're
conducting it in such a way that no one
sees the face of anybody else and the
reason why this works is because for the
most part it's easier for the villains
to remain anonymous if you're a villain
in the Marvel Universe and you're
auctioning off you know what is sure to
be one of the most big-ticket items to
ever have been auctioned off it's gonna
draw a lot of attention from a lot of
different people but that's where the
danger comes into play if these guys
were to take off their masks and then
whoever one ended up winning then
somebody would know who they are and
they could come after them later on and
so that's why it's really important for
them to keep their faces hidden and to
keep themselves as disguise now the
other half of this is that it's also
done for the sake of the story of course
one of these guys here is intelligently
dressed up as one of the little things
from Toy Story one of the little little
guys would agree with the three eyes a
little Vinnie machine guys you know
those those guys do I love those guys
don't really remember too much of them
but I remember laughing a lot when I
first saw it but still it's kind of
interesting here because with them
wearing all these different costumes and
so on you know they kind of go through
like the early bidding phase and one of
the guys is actually dressed up as Iron
Man which is kind of cool he's wearing
an Iron Man mask and what he says here
is the big-ticket item that's up for
auction the DNA of this member of the
superhero community have gotten their
hands on is basically Danielle Cage the
daughter of Luke and Jessica which is
like the least interesting thing ever
and it's kind of funny because it's not
like Tom Taylor was building this other
serious he was just kinda like yeah
everybody's kind of pissed everybody was
kind of expecting this to be like a
pretty big ticket thing except for like
you know Luke and Jessica who basically
freaked off that their daughters their
daughters neo DNA was stolen now the
other half of this is switching back to
the aftermath of this explosion with
Wolverine
of course you end up having Tony Stark
who goes in there starts hunting around
and ultimately ends up finding Logan
who immediately enters into a berserker
rage and goes to kill now that's par for
the course when it comes to Wolverine
one thing to bear in mind when it comes
to Wolverines character he has what's
called a bazooka rage and that's when he
just loses all semblance of self really
enters into like an animalistic state
and just loses the Disco's absolutely
crazy like it's really the most
dangerous version of his character but
he immediately goes into like a
temporary berserker rage and then
regains himself and then essentially
Tony Stark's starts talking to him now
of course punching his hand punching his
his claws into the head of Iron Man as
we know in multiple instances in Marvel
Comics Tony Stark doesn't really fly
around in his suit that often anymore or
at least he doesn't enter into his suit
when he goes into like a hostile area
which is say an area disliked pulsing
with radiation it doesn't make any sense
for him to do that just send in
basically a satellite suit and have the
satellite suit look around while Tony
Stark pilots that remotely but when
Wolverine is talking to the suit you
know by proxy talking to Iron Man what
he essentially says is you have to make
a promise to me like like I know what's
going on here and I'll keep your secret
but you have to make a promise to me and
the promise is if anybody if I end up
dying and anybody ever gets their hands
on my DNA then you have to make sure
that they're basically taken out that
they don't use me for some kind of test
subject they don't like clone me they
don't resurrect me and then turn me into
like a mindless monster or anything like
that because Wolverines been down that
path before like he was uh he was taken
by XI I'm sorry by a Hydra in the hand
he was brainwashed into becoming a
villain
and then in a what if story killed him
all the universe but like he's been down
that road before and he's been used
multiple times it's really the mo of his
character and so in this instance he
says okay fine then I then I'll go ahead
and make sure this doesn't happen now
ultimately what is up going on is like
basically Tony Stark ends up bidding on
the DNA of Daniel Cage to make sure
nobody gets it and it's kind of funny
because once he goes through and starts
doing this is really like for the
benefit of Luke and Jessica but they're
really none too happy about it
now the problem with this is that
somebody ends up realizing Tony Stark is
Tony Stark and so when they basically go
to meet you know as soon as they bounce
out of there they go to meet that guy he
kind of makes this funny comment like I
kind of thought it would go for a lot
more than it did but it didn't but it's
also kind of like hey man you have
Danielle Cage who the hell wants Daniel
cages DNA now Tony Stark kind of chimes
in and says I'm also after the DNA of
Wolverine and this guy says yeah I can
give you that how much you want to pay
and Tony Stark's like yeah like six
million dollars as it was kind of a cool
thing because it means this guy has
access to a vast array of DNA samples
and the reason
this comes with the arrival of mr.
sinister now this fits in perfect for a
variety of reasons one because mr.
sinister is taken over the body of love
you know Tony Stark before but two
because one of the things that you
usually see when it comes to Marvel
Comics when it comes to the x-men kind
of a sidetrack here for a second when it
comes to the villains of the x-men you
don't usually see them cross over with
other members of the superhero community
it took almost like seven or eight years
for like magneto to face like a face-off
against the Avengers for the first time
x-men villains stay x-men villains and
they don't really crossover but it's
kind of a cool thing to see like
sinister pop up and basically Luke Cage
and Jessica Jones in spider-man and an
Tony Stark all react knowing exactly who
he is now a lot of this really stems
from the fact that sinister is a
well-known villain I mean he's a he's a
planetary threat but him lashing out
like this means they have to leave
because sinister is not a foe who's
easily stopped but the other half of
this equation is revealed when we end up
finding out the person who identified
Tony Stark as being Tony Stark is
actually Laura Kenney is x-23 who stowed
away as well because of course she heard
the same thing now again this also makes
sense for her character because one of
the things that has really been hit on
for for all new Wolverine is that for
Laura Kenney she's operated in and out
of MADD reports so showing up here and
facing off against sinister is really
nothing new for her now of course she
slices off his hand in the process which
means that you know he's kind of screwed
he's basically kind of left hanging and
then of course he goes to attack like
the rest you know everybody else and
then you know jessica jones kicks in and
she jumps in different things like that
so on and so forth well the whole place
is flooding you end up having jessica
jones push luke cage against the breach
in the submarine and spider-man webs him
up and leaves him there he's got
impenetrable skin that's gonna stop the
water you know then I get a force law he
cuts off the other hand of sinister
which means he in turn is forced to
retreat now retreating back in and
basically going to figure out where he's
located that means they end up having to
show up show up at his base of
operations we end up finding out these
in a place called the desolation islands
you know the desolation islands if I'm
being honest really kind of feel like a
modern version of the Savage Land
like Avalon or something like I feel
like it's kind of a new version of that
but sinister always does that like he
usually doesn't stay in one main base of
operations for a very long time
she really kind of like bounces around
that way nobody can ever really track
him and so because of this whole thing
of course getting the information out of
Declan Fay the person that worked for
sinister and gain his stuff in the first
place where he was running off and is
kind of selling it to the highest bidder
what the
means is that they can't simply just
enter desolation Islands right I can't
just show up there with like a vessel or
something like that because the defenses
will shoot them all down they basically
need to be small projectiles and so what
happens is like everybody gets Iron Man
armors it's pretty cool I just want to
say luke cage's armor looks badass like
it's literally a giant mace attached to
his hand it looks pretty beast Jessica
Jones is OK spider-man's I think this
Spider Man armor is actually cooler than
the iron spider armor and of course x-23
gets her own suit as well so it's kind
of interesting that like everybody gets
Iron Man armors got busting into the
facility what the end up realizing is
that cynosure is not necessarily there
but what sinister has been doing is
basically stockpiling the DNA of every
being on planet earth like every human
every superhero the whole nine yards now
again this follows perfectly in line
with the Charter of sinister that's why
he's so dangerous is because he's
constantly stockpiling and trying to
find ways to create the perfect villain
the perfect being somebody he can use
for his own ends we don't really know
what the plans for these are and that's
the big question that they have that
sinister is very very intelligent so one
he would have physical copies but then
he would also have digital backups and
so the response is ok download the
digital backups and then in turn destroy
the physical copies the problem they end
up running into is that none of the
mutants are there all the mutant all the
mutant files are basically gone they've
all been erased and then of course
there's all the remaining files for
everybody else now if I were a gambling
man if I were a betting man I would say
given the fact that we're dealing in
desolation islands given the fact that
we're dealing with Wolverine and given
the fact that we're dealing with mr.
sinister and all these different genes I
would say that we're dealing with cetera
I would say that's probably who this is
now cetera flows you guys who don't know
she goes all the way back she he I'm
pretty sure as the she goes all the way
back to Wolverine Punisher revelation
this was back in 1999 and this is a
crossover that dealt with a guy with a
lung sorry with a woman by the name of
revelation who actually emitted a death
aura and the entire basis behind this
death aura is that individuals who come
into contact with it unless they have a
healing factor who will die but there
was basically a recording by cetera that
was left behind that would give
Wolverine knowledge on how to defeat
Revelation now of course a Tara herself
herself is whatever you want to call she
was affiliated with the Morlocks down
below the tunnels in New York I'm pretty
sure that's what we're dealing with here
be wrong but I feel like that's the
direction that we're going in because
you're just talking about a return of a
character that nobody would really
remember that very few people recall but
and would essentially be new to like 90%
of people who are reading Marvel Comics
right now actually I would go out on a
limb and so I would say 99.9% of people
who are reading Marvel Comics right now
had never heard us a tariff I'd say
that's probably what's going on but
anyway of course we end up finding out
that basically everybody here has been
killed they've been absolutely
slaughtered and in turn what's left of
the files are basically downloaded now
of course this basically meets with the
arrival of mr. sinister who's healing
himself because of course he has a
healing factor that's kind of is kind of
his thing and then of course it's the
rest of the superhero team demolishing
sinister quite readily I mean taking it
to him pretty quickly now if in reality
this fight probably shouldn't have
happened there she probably should have
ended that fast I know you're talking
about a guy that can hold his own
against apocalypse I mean not for long
but can hold his own and if apocalypse
were to show up here on the scene they
would all die they really wouldn't stand
a chance I mean how could they possibly
stand a chance to against a guy who can
grow to like 2,000 feet tall and has
every conceivable superpower shy of
reality-warping so I mean he's pretty
damn formidable now of course sinister
is not nearly that powerful but he's
still pretty damn powerful in his own
right so what kind of sucks to see
things would have fall away a little bit
but jummy back to the past with
Wolverine again what we end up finding
out is the secret he's harboring is that
this weapon that was here this bomb that
had gone off with stark technology it
was stark tech and so basically it's
it's Wolverine saying you do this favor
for me you make sure nobody ever uses me
as an experiment and I will keep your
secret safe I will let nobody know that
you're the person who's doing this that
you guys you're the person that had this
bomb now the other half of this is that
it seems from what Wolverine tells us
this bomb was built as like a deterrent
that had Iron Man lost civil war that
possibly this bomb would have been used
and is essentially like Wolverine sent
sitting down and saying like what you've
done here over the course of your entire
career is just consistently screw things
up you almost destroyed your company
because you were an alcoholic you almost
lost everybody that meant anything to
you because you were an alcoholic you've
almost died on several occasions and you
actually died once everything you touch
dies you have to get it together you've
screwed this up you have to move things
in a direction to where the world
becomes a better place and so this is
kind of Tom Taylor sort of injecting a
bit of a retcon in just say why Ironman
had this kind of paradigm shift you know
why you have this this this massive
change because we're sinister tries to
organ and say look take what you've won
you'll take the information you want but
leave the digital files here
Iron Man record Lex back to the promise
he made to Wolverine and says we got to
destroy the soul
I promise Wolverine that I would destroy
all this it's all gotta go it's all got
to disappear and it's all got to be
eliminated so that even if Wolverines
files aren't here these can't be used
for some kind of a nefarious purpose so
all these things are annihilated in
their entirety and so it's basically him
just kind of picking up and you know
after after the aftermath of all this
him just kind of picking up and saying
one of the things that I found here you
know going through and looking at those
files Tony Stark says my job is to be
extremely intelligent my job is to see
the things no one else sees as one of
the reasons why I'm the most not one of
the most knowledgeable people out there
in the Marvel Universe and is always
going to those files I only got a
glimpse but what I've learned here is
that one of the mutants that exists out
there in the x-men community is not a
mutant they basically had their genes
modified to make them look like a mutant
but they're not of you somebody out
there is is a fraud somebody out there
is a fake and we got to figure out who
that person is continuing on into
basically what seems to be like dead
ends which is gonna be kind of cool I
think and it's gonna be interesting
because hopefully it turns out to be
Iron Man versus the x-men that's really
kind of what I want to see it's high
time we get like an Iron Man versus the
x-men story by God the guy's been around
for almost 50 years it's time for us to
see that all that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here too comments explained make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the robb for if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]